just a matter of hours Southwest Airline
Jets back in the sky and again good
evening to you I'm Brian Loftus here at
11. now the company reports it's
planning to return to normal operations
Friday thousands of Travelers do remain
separated from their luggage Ryan
Matthey shows us how they're being
reunited
for weeks now Flyers have been without
their clothes their medications and
their Christmas presents it's because
they're in bags just like these that
were checked into their flight before
those flights were canceled now their
owners are beginning to get them back
I don't know where in the nation is my
bag they keep delayed delayed delayed
six hours so we said where is our
suitcase the meeting is one of thousands
who never made it on their scheduled
flight but bags did Southwest Airlines
moved Jets out of bad weather before
they had the staff to offload luggage
already on the plane Jing says she's
been without her belongings for four
days and just got them back Thursday
it's not a lot because it's Christmas
gift here someone else's or gift to see
in here I'm so sorry you have to wait
the customer service line still an hour
or longer wait on the phone so instead
Travelers are coming to their
destination airports where Southwest
Personnel some stranded flight
attendants themselves looked through
thousands my son went to the airport in
Denver and they told him that the bags
were shipped to Vegas Lee kistner's son
has already made it home after driving
to Las Vegas when his Christmas flight
was canceled his bags finally made it to
Reed International days later trying to
get the bags back a little bit
frustrating from Southwest with lack of
communication however the people here at
the airport have been fantastic we did
ask to speak to a Southwest manager here
that request was denied their corporate
office telling me instead that they have
a massive effort underway to reunite all
those bags with their owners reporting
from Harry Reid International Ryan
Matthey a news now